Android patterns for performance
When it comes to performance,
One approach controls computing.
Without it, it was not your computer
To exist or operate at all.
I'm Joanna Smith.
I confirm that buffering is essential for performance
And to design the devices in your phone.
If you think about it, you'll find a clear reason
Computers contain RAM.
It acts as a data cache
Provides access to up-to-date information very quickly
Compared to getting them from your hard drive.
This is exactly the definition of the cache:
A place to store frequently used data
Until future use is done as soon as possible.
At any time you bear the burden of pressure
To calculate, download, or find part of data,
The cache can do this more quickly and efficiently
The second and third time and so forth.
In your application, it is the most common case for gains from buffering
Is when you have data calculated several times
But with the same result always.
No one will oppose the transfer of unchanging activities in an internal loop,
But you might be surprised at how easy it is to do it unwittingly.
Think of a simple example
Where the derived number is calculated for a 4 × 4 matrix
For use when calculating cyclic repeat control variable.
But that matrix is ​​never changed within annular repetition;
So you are wasting performance
Recalculate the derivative number with each frequency.
You can instead calculate and save the result outside the loop repeat
And make the inner parts of the ring repeat
Indicates that cached result.
It may seem obvious when presented in this way,
But you will be surprised that even the veteran developers fall into this trap.
Such as calling Get Current User
Inside loop replication in a single user environment, such as a game on mobile.
Spooling also acts as a great resource for limited resource environments.
Suppose, for example, that you have about 2 GB of images that a user may need to view,
But you can only fit 50 MB of them in memory at a time.
The Android window will help you as much as you can if you're using the adapter view.
But you can increase the efficiency of this
By tracking the types of images that should be saved in memory
And those that should be eliminated
So the frame does not need to evaluate the entire 2 GB content.
There is a less common type of caching
Known as "pre-computing".
This type occurs when you spend time offline
Calculates a huge search table or an enormous XML schema
So that at run time you can fetch that data
Instead of performing all those costly tasks as the user waits for you.
This is the main idea: Avoid unnecessary actions.
So if you're looking to make performance improvements
Or trying to create a new application with perfect performance,
It loses the places in which cyclic repetition occurs
Or data download or dense computing
Find out what you can modify there.
Avoiding unnecessary actions is almost everything we talk about
In the rest of the Android Performance Patterns and in the G + community;
So you lose both.
So keep calm, collect your code information
Always remember that performance is important.